请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
那我们先打开我们的挑选股棋小帮手
各位
挑选股棋小帮手会告诉你
这个你想存的股票
看这里面有没有
所以你手上有库存的
你记得打开看
第一个先看它有没有
你0050有没有
有
那你就看静元月价差
这个是负的0.01
那这个就没什么搞头啦
0.1没什么搞头
我记得以前0050
它的近元月价差有时候还会到0.2 0.3
我们现在看到
这边有个近元月价差
近元月价差你必须要找到负的
那负的数值呢
当然是越高越好
但有些负的数值
它会跟它的股价有关啦
哇
这个也不错
哎
川普呢
负3块
相当于每个月配息大概4块
各位你算看看
每个月配息4块
然后呢
12個月就配40幾塊
還不錯欸
沒有 我沒有特別的去追蹤他每天要買賣什麼
因為每天要看東西太多了
所以我沒有特別去追蹤
夜輝有期貨嗎
夜輝我是用個股啊
夜輝有期貨這東西嗎
沒有期貨啊
誒 成澤變好了誒
誒 還不錯
好
成澤好像線型變得比較漂亮
所以各位
你可以用期货来做啦
那期货呢不用花你太多保证金哦各位你看看这边这些期货保证金有的都很便宜啊你看这边那個沒有期貨價格就會變成沒有保存金哇你看這星光金才2300而已
小穩帽才2400
然後呢它的近遠月的價差有到-0.5
你可以這樣想喔
-0.5那你要乘以100股
所以將大約50塊
每個月多個50塊的配型
但是它那種配型喔
比較奇怪
他不是说给你50块 他没有
他是做了一个价差让你赚到50块啦
就是你去买价差单的话 你会发现
你有冒的可能就是这个月的卖掉卖152
下个月买151.5回来
你的对样单就会这样写
所以呢
这个呢就是价差的意思啦
然后
Brice Andy说
转仓付价差是否可能赚了月配期
跌了价差 当然会啊
没错啊 当然是这样
跟股票的概念一样 好不好
就像假設你去買恆大配型
我們現在對航運股要尊敬一點
不要亂講航運股
你買恆大配型
你看當時候配型呢配的蠻漂亮的
配的12塊
那你拿到12塊代表你賺到這12塊嗎
也不一定
它沒有天行就是沒有賺到
那轉倉付價差
至少它讓你每個月的成本都掉0.5
然後呢我們這樣講
假設他每個月都0.5的話
怎麼樣
哇那以為我貌幾乎是零成本你懂我意思嗎副價差的標的表示大貨不看好未來價格不一定喔
不是這樣講
喔 有時候只是
避險的需求
它跟未來的狀況不一定一樣
有時候是人家避險的需求
喔 所以呢
呃 避險需求呢
這個
就会有人持续性的空单
例如说我之前
我的成德是空单
那你说我是看空成德吗
我并没有
我并没有看空他
我只是在做动态避险套利而已
我成德的期货是空单
但我的可转债有一堆多单
那成德只是我避险而已
就是
我经由成德期货来做动态避险
成德涨我也赚
成德跌我也赚
这两个都赚
那你说我看空成德吗
我才没有看空乘的
我是看多的好不好
我手上乘的可转载的多单比期货的空单来得多
所以我是看多的
我看多的
可是我持有空单
所以呢
这并不是代表说
大户它一定是看空哦
就像正的不代表说
大户一定是看多哦
只是很有可能是这样
但是不是一定
那台积电可不可以用这个来存呢
台积電我們就要看它的
架差單漂不漂亮
靜遠架差喔 這小型有到0.63
我們來看大型的
大型的是0.62台積電呢 可能就沒那麼漂亮因為它是架差單是為正但是呢假设你是去空台积电的人其实台积电这个价差呢就很漂亮
这个正的对空单有利
那负的呢对多单有利
所以呢你要看看
你是做多还是做空呢
那现在只要很多大户都是在做空的话
那么呢对我们这些存股票的人
那么你就会看到会有很多的股票
它就会开始变成负的加差单
那我们看负的加差单有谁啊
刚刚看到有这个川儒创意威胜啊
好
各位
你手上有这几档股票的
赶快卖掉
懂我意思吗
换成期货
再讲一次哦
赶快卖掉
换成期货
然后呢
你就可以这样子
一个月一个月的转仓
你就用这个来转仓
那用转仓
例如说创意
这个纪元价差差了4块
4块钱
一年多了
大概48块
所以扣掉交易成本
我们算45块好了
你把两张创意
换成一口创意
或是一百股创意
换成一个小型创意
你改变这个观念之后
你就可以每个月赚到红利